[Music]
hey guys over a year ago I introduced
with a theory in which Danny will
sacrifice her life to save Westeros for
the long night she'll become the next
week however upon re-watching the show
and rereading books over and over again
I came up two more clue sang-hee in
supporting his theory and so I decided
to update it with a few great points
before I introduced with the new hints
and close let's first take a look on the
close we had before before we do it
let's take a quick look at who the night
screen even was in the first place the
night screen is a legendary figure known
as Seven Kingdoms in among the free folk
according to a legend the Lord Commander
of the Nights Watch fun in haunted
forests a cold woman with bright blue
eyes he took her to the other side of
the wall and declared himself the
night's king their love and reign lasted
for 13 years whereupon the free folk
rallied under the banner of a
king-beyond-the-wall in march against
the night king seating in the night fort
which resulted with the night's king the
faith with the aid of House Stark now
that you know a little bit about the
night screen let's start with a theory
in which Danny will become the same
Queen earlier in Game of Thrones who
learned that the leader of the White
Walkers the night king is able to create
other White Walkers but it seems that he
can only create one if that human being
is a pure-blooded incest born as some
kind of proof we have a few scenes in
which Crestor was sacrificing his incest
porn babies we have a scene from the
fourth season in which rest places
Craster's final son on the ground in the
haunted first rap on a white walker
approach took the baby and then carried
it towards the shattered mountain in the
lands of always winter once the white
Walker approached a nice shelter ringed
by large I see spikes he plays the baby
up on the altar upon the night King
approached gently gathered the baby in
his arms and place his index finger upon
the baby's cheek which caused the
child's eyes to turn eyes see blue and
its skin to grow pale the scene from the
fourth episode of season 4 in my opinion
confirmed my statement that only says
born pure blooded human beings can
become a by walk while every other human
beings can only become a white a
reanimated corpse raised from a death by
the white walkers to act as their
minions all of this means that the night
king could turn Dany into one of them
since then is a pure-blooded incest born
daughter of King Aerys and Queen rhaella
Targaryen the greatest or the only word
that matters is not coming anymore it's
here winter is here now and is seemingly
only way to end the long night is to
defeat the night king this would be
insanely hard but that's the way that
living will first go for that's the way
they are definitely going to experience
the way which will take a huge amount of
casualties in the only way which will
only make the undead army bigger since
all the brave soldiers that are going to
fall on the battlefield
against the army of the Dead will be
revived by the white walkers as whites
make no mistake the nikes army will go
bigger and bigger by the day now that
they have finally passed the wall their
numbers will drastically grow upon huge
losses and upon realizing that the
chance of defeating the night king is
small the living side will decide to
stop fighting and will try to establish
peace we'll try to arrange a pact with
the leader at White Walkers John and
then he will realize that the only way
for the living side to end the long
night at that point would be a pact an
agreement with the leader of the army of
the Dead the night king a pact of fights
and fire an agreement that includes
Danny have you ever wondered why isn't a
king even coming south why was he
preparing an army all those years with
which he started marching south at the
moment of Dana's arrival at Westeros in
this theory Danny's arrival at Westeros
is the reason of the nat Kings
preparations the reason of his march
south and the reason of every single
death that the Seven Kingdoms is going
to confront during this long night
before we get on all the details of this
pact it's a foreign highlight that Danny
could have on the throne as soon as she
arrived at Westeros if she wanted to she
didn't attack King's Landing because she
did not want to cause death upon
millions of innocent people and she will
not ever sit on the Iron Throne because
she will decide to give up her life so
those people including her child could
live then his visions are for sharing
that Dany could is living the Iron
Throne but it also shows that she would
realize that she will not be able to sit
on the same since she'll have to give up
on it for the greater good then he will
agree to make a pact between the living
side and the dead an agreement in which
she ends long night by becoming unite
screen to the night king
saving all the Westeros from certain
death some might say that you can uh
negotiate with the night King and White
Walkers but that might not be true
Crestor negotiated a deal with White
Walkers and as long as he provided a
steady supply of sons they agreed to
leave him and his daughter wives alone
then he will accept a pact and she'll
become the night's queen whereupon the
night King and Danny will go beyond the
wall and rule over it as a form of peace
agreement between the living and the
dead beside Dana's vision says I've
already said earlier in this video Denis
arrival at Westeros and Annette King
preparations and his march to the South
fits perfectly in timeline as well I
don't think it's coincidence that all
those years the night King was preparing
and gathering huge army with which he
started marching south at the same time
of Dana's arrival at Westeros also the
fact that is showing clothing multiple
scenes are proving that the night King
can create other White Walkers only that
human being is a pure-blooded incest
born which Dany among the very few is
not to mention she's the only says born
main character has to be for sharing
something huge Danny
in the serie dying hands of Jon Snow
home to shortly after opening her eyes
as the night swing one of the most
prominently accepted game of Thrones fan
theories for a while now is that Justin
is the modern incarnation of us were
high well then he will likely play the
role of Lisa nice same bringing the long
night to its end bosses bunty's amazes
Marek Evo Doral Aras was mahogany's the
prince he was promised will bring the
door and you believe this prophecy
refers to me prophecies are dangerous
things I believe you have a role to play
as does another the King in the north
John so the other high legend stayed
there during the first long night the
hero forges sword made of flames named
light bringer supposedly it saved all of
the humanity from the white walkers the
forging of such a strong weapon came at
a price says as her I had to thrust the
sword through his own wife's living
heart so her blood soul strength and
courage could go into the steel source
also once explained that this man that
reborn as a rival also need to pierce a
sword to a loving wife scarred because
great power requires great sacrifice
according to prophecy our champion will
be reborn to wake dragons from stone and
reforge the great sword Lightbringer
that defeated the darkness those
thousands of years ago
if the old tales are true a terrible
weapon forged with the lifeblood of a
loving wife's heart part of me thinks
man was well rid of it the great power
requires great sacrifice yes george RR
martin constantly warns fans to not take
these ancient legends too literally in
game films if painting there lots of
details are lost the time and headshots
become fact through centuries of
misinformation what I believe is that
azor Ahai did not actually kill his
beloved wife to create the weapon that
brought back the dawn rather man her
blood and soul and strength entered the
sword the process turned her into white
Walker sounds familiar
anyways there's no doubt that light
bringer has a sword that was able to
kill white walkers was made out of
Valyrian steel as most of you probably
know the secret of forging Valyrian
steel was lost in the doom of Valyria so
no one knows how people used to make
these sorts however a popular opinion is
that Valyrian steel is forged with
genuine glass since both materials are
capable of destroying by walkers as we
learned in monoprints flashbacks
journalists can also transform living
humans into white walkers so it's quite
possible that Valyrian steel can just
the same but why would as her hide do
such thing to his wife why would John
stone piers Sloan clawed through Dana's
heart it's hard to believe that a single
man defeated the entire army the derrial
flaming sword he forged by killing his
wife since it's highly unlikely that
azor Ahai killed hundreds of thousands
strong army of the night King with a
high bring her during the first long
night it's possible that as her height
shows diplomacy and peace 2010 save all
of Westeros as otherwise they probably
would have all died for centuries the
Great Houses have been securing their
political alliances with marriage so
perhaps that's exactly the best way to
make peace with the night King Danny
agrees to become his wife denied screen
Veerappan they will go beyond the wall
to rule over it and agree to never cross
it again
of course Danny could not just become
the night screen without most of people
even knowing who the night screen even
is meaning that for this theory to come
true it have to see one or two
flashbacks of the first long night as
well as of unite screen herself and not
only that but for this theory to come
true brain would have to go back into
the first long night to see how did a
living managed to end along night brain
was had to see deleting make a deal with
the dead but also to see azor Ahai
piercing a Valyrian steel sword to Nyssa
niece's heart and witness that it wasn't
his famous hero who single-handedly
destroyed army of diarrheal flaming
sword as legend says but it was rather
his Valyrian steel sword that created
the night screen which effect and in the
long night well the season eight filming
Lee seem to be confirming that it's
exactly what we'll get in the final
season reportedly season eight of Game
of Thrones will see one important
character played by Laura Alton stone
and as old media reported she'll most
likely play the night Kings wife in a
flashback I would assume in conclusion
Danny Neeson in Seville in this series
died in the hands of Jon Snow Azure hi
and shortly after Oprah rises the
night's Queen heading beyond the wall
with the night's king fulfilling the
other high prophecy ending along night
and saving all of Westeros just as every
true Queen would do for her people not
only that this theory would be one of
the greatest surprises that showrunners
could pull out but it will also fit
perfectly with a bittersweet ending that
George our Martin announced we free folk
have our stories - about how one of your
king crows found something cold no words
with bright blue eyes how he brought her
home through your wall and declared
himself night's king
thirteen years he and his queen ruled
over his brothers making sacrifices as
black as their clocks looking for you
cylinders the free folk rallied to a
king-beyond-the-wall as we will when
need be and march on the ancient castle
he taken for his own the night thought
with the help of the Starks we killed
the diamond and cleansed your precious
watch and as always I hope you guys
enjoyed this video if you did please
make sure to subscribe to our Channel
and I hope to see you in the next one
beast
[Music]